في اخبارنا الاخرى فاز المرشح الجمهوري
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب في
الانتخابات التمهيديه للحزب الجمهوري في
ولايه ايوا مثبتا موقفه كمرشح اكثر حظا
بنيل ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري هذا فيما
يتسابق كل من حاكم ولايه فلوريدا رون
ديسانتس والمندوب الامريكيه السابقه لدى
الامم المتحده نيك هيلي على المكانه
الثانيه تحظى التجمعات الانتخابيه في
ولايه اي باهميه لونها الاولى وتعطي زخما
للمرشح الفائز في باقي
السباقات للمتابعه معنا من مدينه ديمون في
ولايه ايوا مراسله الجزيره بيسان ابو كويك
بيسان اي اهميه لهذا الفوز بالنسبه لترامب
الذي يعني عانى على المستوى
القضائي نشوان هذا الفوز يعطي ترامب زخما
مضي قدما في هذه الحمله الانتخابيه نحن
الان فعليا ورسميا في
بدايه هذا السباق الانتخابي الذي سيكون
طويل من هنا الى الصيف حين يتم بالفعل
اختيار مرشح الحزب الجمهوري في مؤتمر
الحزب وطبعا الى نوفمبر حين ينافس ذلك
الحزب المرشح الديمقراطي وهو حتى اللحظه
المؤشرات تشير الى الرئيس ال حالي جو
بايدن بالنسبه لترامب الاستطلاعات كانت قد
اشارت الى انه يتقدم على منافسيه خصوصا
نيكي هيلي ورون ديسانتس حتى اللحظه تشير
الارقام والنتائج الاوليه انه يحظى ب 50%
من الاصوات التي تم فرزها حتى الان في حين
يحتل روندي سنتس ويحصل على
21% مقابل ت 19% عفوا لنيكي هيلي وهذه
المكانه الثانيه التي يتنافس عليها
الاثنان هذه الولايه ولايه صغيره ت تصوت
في الانتخابات العامه في نوفمبر
للجمهوريين بشكل عام لديها 40 مندوب ت
يمثلها في مؤتمر الحزب الجمهوري التوقعات
ان ترامب بالنسبه التي حاز عليها من
الاصوات حتى الان حاز على 16 مندوبا طبعا
هذه الانتخابات تعطيه زخم الاسبوع القادم
هناك انتخابات في ولايه نيو هامشير من
بعدها نيفادا ومن بعدها ساوث كارولاينا
ومن ثم يوم الثلاثاء الكبير وبعدها ربما
تتضح الصوره ربما من سيكون قد
نال المزيد من الفوز في انتخابات اخرى
والمزيد من المندوبين بالنسبه لترامب ما
تكشف من الذين شاركوا في هذا التجمع
التجمعات في هذه الولايه ليست انتخابات
تقليديه هي تتم في نهايه اليوم ليس لها
موعد محدد للانتهاء يتج جمع الناخبون في
اماكن متعدده عبر الولايه يستمعون لممثلين
عن المرشحين ومن ثم تتم عمليه الاقتراع
والذين يشاركون في تلك التجمعات جمهوريون
فقط مسجلين في الحزب الجمهوري سته من عشره
من الذين استطلع من الذين شاركوا في هذه
التجمعات هذه الليله يقولون انهم يؤيدون
ترامب حتى لو تمت ادانته في القضايا وفي
التي يواجهها ترامب
يواجه نحو 90 تهمه في قضايا متعدده جنائيه
واخرى فيدراليه ومنها ما يتعلق
بالانتخابات الرئاسيه اللافت ايضا ان ثلثي
م من استطلعت ارائهم ممن شاركوا في
التجمعات في هذه الولايه تحديدا يعتبرون
ان بايدن ليس رئيسا شرعيا وما زالوا
يؤمنون بان ترامب هو الذي فاز في انتخابات
2 20 وان الانتخابات تعرضت لتزوير وهذه
طبعا ربما محور بعض القضايا والتهم التي
يواجهها ترامب على المستوى الفيدرالي
خصوصا على خلفيه الهجوم على الكونجرس في
السادس من
يناير هذه الانتخابات عاده خصوصا في هذه
الولايه ايوا تتمحور حول القضايا الداخليه
اقتصاديه والهجره ولكن حتى السياسه
الخارجيه كان ه مكان خصوصا في ظل الحرب
الجاريه على قطم اي مراس الجزيره بيس شكرا
جزيلا لك